Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Connors again, and we're ready for another session of our holistic health hour.
Remember, we got a lot of questions that came in.
So we'll have those to go over, but if you do have questions that you want to chat in, hopefully we'll get to those as well.
I hope we will make those next week. Sometimes when we get chats in, I don't always get them.
So I do apologize in advance, but I don't see your chat questions.
So just remember to always go on our site, the holistichealthhour.com site to see, to post questions as well.
And go to our blog post on cuttersclinic.com.
See you in an ERSclinic.com, where you can search for questions on our website.
We have well over a thousand blog posts or YouTube channel too, and our new video channel, which is videos dot cuttersclinic.com.
We have well over a thousand videos too, so try to get your questions answered anyway.
We possibly can. But anyhow, let's jump into this.
First question. I have thyroid antibodies.
I have a thyroid antibodies for 30 years. Chronic line had mold colonization.
I'm an at your path. So done a stack of cleansing.
I don't appear to react to a violent stimulant, such as cats, clock, a straggolus, andrographis and agnesia.
Although I take the latter to less frequently.
I'm not sure what this person means by that they don't react to it, whether they don't react negatively or doesn't help them with a positive standpoint.
I use AO bioresidents and have come up with high ochre toxin and some citrinated and MPA.
Those are all mycotoxins.
I did six months ago. I'm impressed by your acute chronic and AI products.
Those are products that I formulated for autoimmune issues and Lyme conditions.
And question, which of these would you believe would be beneficial?
My scanner on the bioresidents is consistently telling me that I need anti-microbials and Artemisidia,
and you as well as mushrooms.
First of all, if a person has thyroid antibodies and you're still showing TPO or thyroid antibodies,
that means that you either have Hashimoto disease or Graves disease if it's a hyperthyroid state.
I assume that it's a hypothyroid, Hashimoto's.
If that is still true, you still show positive antibodies to thyroid.
This is 30 years going.
And you're still having issues. That's why you're asking the question.
I would suggest that you consider at least doing some other antibody testing.
So when a person has antibodies to self-tissue, that means every time you stimulate an immune response,
either artificially stimulated immune response from exogenous source of sources,
and by this I mean that you're purposely trying to stimulate the immune system to kill some pathogen
or something like your taking vitamin C or your taking some of these products that this person mentioned,
cats, claws, straggalists, endopropas, echinacea, these are all immune stimulated herbs.
So if you're taking immune stimulated herbs, so again you're trying to stimulate your immune system
for whatever reason from an outside-in source where you're taking supplements to do that.
And you have self antibodies, you will, the danger of doing that is you will destroy self-tissue.
So remember, when you stimulate your immune system, either from an exogenous source,
you're taking supplements to try to kill something, or from an endogenous source,
meaning that your immune system is up-regulated because you are exposed to a virus,
or you get a cold, or you get a, you know, a sore throat or something.
And your immune system increases production of killer cells.
You're gonna kill that once you have antibodies against, first, that's a whole idea of having antibodies.
So if you have self antibodies, mean antibodies to self-tissue, meaning you have an autoimmune disease,
and you have an optic of your immune system, you will cause more destruction of that tissue.
So that's what you have to be careful about, if you have an autoimmune disease,
this is a major, major mistake that people make, if they don't know that they have an autoimmune disease.
It's never been discovered, why? Because it's never been tested for.
The only way you're gonna know if you have an autoimmune disease is if you tested for self antibodies.
Now, it's fairly common that a person would test for thyroid antibodies,
because if you're really gonna do a proper thyroid workup,
you're gonna test for TPO and thyrogobular antibodies, which, that doesn't really account for anything,
because even you could go to an endocratologist for hypothyroidism,
they never even test for antibodies, believe it or not, which is absolutely valve-practice.
But many times people don't test for other antibodies.
I mean, it's not, they might test for ANA antibodies, which is a systemic autoimmune disorder.
They might test for lupus. In other ways, they might test for antibodies to different viruses,
like it's not uncommon to get an MC-MAR virus antibody test.
But it is relatively less common that a person goes to a doctor,
even a functional medicine doctor, and they do appropriate antibody testing.
I think that can be an error. I think it's always wise to rule out other autoimmune disorders,
meaning that do you have antibodies to neural tissue?
Do you have antibodies to other tissues, so that you know if you have an end,
if you do have an autoimmune disease, then you know you have to be careful
in using different nutrition the wrong way.
I'm all for using herbals to stimulate an immune response to kill cancer,
or to kill a bacterial infection, or a chronic bacterial infection.
But if you have, you're doing that with a person, and you have auto antibodies,
when you have antibodies to self-tissue, or you would never test it for these,
then you could actually do more harm than good.
For every time you increase the immune response, either artificially through using herbals.
Like I said, you will kill that with your antibodies against first,
so I think you should test for that.
So what should you use?
I mean the reason why I created that acute LX, chronic LX, and the AI products
is that I really created them with, in the mind,
if a person has acute Lyme disease, or acute viral infection, or acute bacterial infection,
a chronic Lyme disease, chronic viral infection, chronic bacterial infection,
that would be the acute LX and the chronic LX, and then the AI is,
if you're in the autoimmune phase, there's no immune stimulants in it.
So if you're going to try to support your body,
when you have an autoimmune disease, you can't be using TH1 stimulants.
You can't be using immune stimulants.
So if you want my advice on what you should take,
you should only take the AI product, or something similar to that.
If you look at the ingredients on our store site, you'll want to purchase something similar,
and if you have something similar in your cabinet,
your idea is that you're not taking things that are going to be immune stimulants.
My scanner tests that I need for antimicrobials.
Well, again, your scanner might test for the need for antimicrobials,
which your scanner cannot test for auto antibiotics.
So you have to be, I guess, a more broad spectrum practitioner,
in the fact that you're going to look at auto antibiotics.
So if a person comes up that they have a viral infection,
or a product bacterial infection, you still don't just jump on that way.
You're going to try to kill that virus, or kill that bacteria,
without looking at the bigger picture.
You've got to test for auto antibodies.
And you already know you have thyroid auto antibodies.
You just have to know that if you're going to take a immune stimulant,
you're going to kill more of your thyroid, and you could,
even if it's been fairly balanced,
and you've been able to keep it in balance with whatever things you're doing,
that could throw it away out of balance.
Artemisinin, Artemisia anula,
which is Artemisinin, is an immune stimulant.
So Artemisinin is a great antiviral.
It's a great product for a product line,
but once a product line blows into that phase three,
and it's an autoimmune phase that you have to be careful with Artemisinin.
Mushrooms are your safe or bad, because mushrooms are not direct immune stimulants.
Mushrooms are more immune regulators,
meaning if you need an uptick and an immune response for a period of time,
it will help uptick that if your immune system is already in a hyper-functional state.
In many cases, with autoimmune disease, it will call that down.
Mushrooms tend to act more as an immune regulator.
It is dose-dependent, though.
More and more studies are coming out that different nutrients work in your body differently,
dose-dependently.
So I would say if you're going to take high dose, so 3-she or my attack eat,
it's going to be more of an immune stimulant.
If you're going to take a lower dose of those things, it could act as a more immune regulator.
Cortiseps and tert-etail are going to be more immune regulators.
You're going to have to go pretty high dose for it to be more immune stimulator.
Okay, so I hope that helps.
I didn't tell you exactly what to take, but really to do more testing, I think, with you guys.
Next question.
Punch biopsy of husbands.
Center cheek showed squamous cell carcinoma.
What treatments can he have done for the cancer of his cheek
and the cancer cells that have traveled to other parts of his body from the biopsy?
Heard that most surgery or radiation and chemo won't kill the cancer stem cells
and carcinoma will come back with a vengeance to that same spot on his face.
Well, first I want to call your heart that don't believe everything you hear
because those things can happen.
So let's explain this a little bit.
So a tumor on a person's face was tested.
Again, I'm just reading these questions as a chance to look at these.
Squamous cell carcinoma.
We have several different types of cancer, skin cancer.
The most common three is melanoma, which is the most serious.
Squamous cell carcinoma, which can be equally serious.
And then basal cell, which typically is not serious.
So basal cell carcinoma, I have no problem with the person X-I-Z knows
tumors if they want to, even though I think it will be wise to try some topical things
because you can use a curcumin cream.
You can use different essential oils on basal cell tumors
and you can have pretty good effects.
And then you don't have any scars from X-I-Z knows tumors.
Squamous cell carcinoma is much more serious.
Typically with squamous cell and with melanoma,
they're going to do a surgery called a mose surgery.
What a mose surgery is is they take out everything that they can see visually.
They'll understand cells are small.
You can't see them, right?
You're seeing masses of cells.
That's what you see.
So even when a surgeon goes in and removes a mass,
let's say it's a six-centimeter mass in the liver,
you can only get what they see that they take out a little bit more tissue
so that they're hoping to get what is called a clear margin.
That's what a mose surgery is.
Typically we're talking about skin cancer removal,
is that they're removing it deeper than what they could see.
They immediately said that the pathology, that's examined.
If it gets, I think it's three centimeters of clear margins,
then they call it good.
If they're like, oh, it's not three centimeters of clear margin,
they're going to go a little deeper.
Look at pathology results.
Oh, it's still not getting, their margins are going a little deeper.
That's what's called a mose surgery.
That's typically done on a squamous cell or melanoma.
With basal cell, I think they just go visually.
But positives and negatives in that.
The positives are that you're devolking the cancer.
So whatever you're surgically removing a cancer,
whether it be a breast cancer or you're removing a lump,
so that's called a lumpectomy or you go to mastectomy,
you're doing a, you're removing the majority of visual mass.
So the positive thing is that if you're going to do other things,
whether it's going after removing the mass or the devolking of the cancer,
if you're going to do other things,
then you reduce the load on your immune system.
So if you think of it, if that my immune system,
I'm going to try to boost my immune system to try to kill cancer
and I have this mass, whether it be a one centimeter mass
that's maybe two to three millimeters deep in a skin cancer
or it be a one centimeter row mass in a breast
or a two centimeter row mass in my liver.
Deep, bulky, the cancer is the term that we give
that you're going in there and surgically removing
every thing that you possibly can.
So the idea is just to remove everything.
It's to remove what you, you're just trying to use
your best common sense possible.
So you remove what is visual and by removing that
as much active cancer that you can find,
the positive is is that you remove the burden of your immune system
to have to destroy that.
So then you could work on stimulating your immune system
to clean up any other cancer cells that you have.
So like this person alluded to what could I do to help with the cancer cells
that have traveled to other parts of the body from the biopsy.
So cancer cells that that leaves an original primary tumor
and travel elsewhere in the body are called circulating tumor cells.
So circulating tumor cells are our cancerous in the aspect
of they're not healthy cells, meaning with a healthy functioning mitochondria
and a healthy functioning nucleus.
So if you have a damaged nuclei in the cell,
they're traveling to other parts of your body,
hoping to, like I always say,
send up home and raise a family someplace else.
That's what their purpose is.
With cancer cells, with differentiates cancer cells
from non-cancer cells,
as cancer cells, something got inside the cell.
Something got inside the cell.
At some point in time it damaged the nucleus,
or replication.
Now when cancer cells are at a state of rapid replication,
they're replicated unhealthy cells that are also have that damaged nucleus
and are rapidly replicated.
So when you see a cancer that is one centimeter large,
that's millions and millions and millions and millions and millions of cells.
So there's going to be cells that are given up long before you're even diagnosed with cancer.
If you just go in for a mammogram and you find this little spot,
it's really little spot.
So we want to do an ultrasound and maybe do a needle biopsy of this spot.
Well, long before you do the biopsy,
and long before this person did the biopsy of this quamous cell,
carcinoma, on their face,
they already gave off,
that cancer has already given up thousands and thousands,
maybe millions of circulating tumor cells that are traveling throughout the body,
trying to grow somewhere else.
Now what's keeping that at bay is your immune system.
So that's what's keeping circulating tumor cells at bay,
from setting up another place and growing again.
If it does that, that's called metastasis.
Now is there a risk this person alluded to?
What do I do to keep that at bay from other parts of the body from the biopsy?
So that phrase from the biopsy could say,
well, that's conspiratorial.
There's no way kids, the biopsies,
cause it increase risk of metastasis.
But actually there is documentation that does show that that does happen.
There's a couple articles that were written a few years ago,
and the ones that I looked at were on breast cancer biopsies.
And it does increase the risk of metastasis.
But I will say skim cancer biopsies,
whether you're biopsy, the center,
a punch biopsy,
or the center of the tumor,
your risk of increasing circulating tumor cells
from the biopsy is much smaller than what was documented as a needle biopsy.
Possible complications from breast cancer.
Because what you think of it,
you're sticking the needle into the breast.
I didn't know how deep that tumor is.
You're going in there excising some cells through the needle,
but then you're pulling the needle through that breast tissue.
The closer the tumor is to the surface,
the less risk you have of spreading cancer throughout the rest of the breast.
That's your pulling that needle back out through.
So the deeper the tumor is,
the greater risk you have of increasing the spread of the cancer.
So with the skim cancer, obviously,
you're not spreading it through any tissue.
That is not cancerous.
So I don't think that I would be worried about the circulating tumor cells from the biopsy.
However, that being said,
what I said previously,
by the time you have,
the time you have recognized that something is wrong,
and you have to go in and get a check,
your body is already given out,
tons of circulating tumor cells.
From a nutritional standpoint,
from a medical standpoint,
no, they don't do anything for circulating tumor cells.
From a functional standpoint,
you can actually measure circulating tumor cells,
but it's only going to measure the circulating tumor cells in the blood.
That is not going to measure circulating tumor cells
that have already settled somewhere in the tissue.
So I don't even particularly like that test,
because it could give you false hope that,
oh, my circulating tumor cells are zero.
So yeah, I'm clear.
That doesn't actually mean that.
However, so from a functional nutritional standpoint,
what do you do for circulating tumor cells?
Probably the number one thing that you would do for circulating tumor cells
is modified citrus pectin.
So there's a product called pectusol C.
That's a modified citrus pectin.
I'll just get something that's this citrus pectin.
Certainly don't get something that's this pectin.
It's modified citrus pectin, pectusol C.
I write about it in my book,
Stop Biting Kids, or two,
and you could look at it on our store.
I probably have multiple articles on our blog.
Modified citrus pectin.
So look that up.
That would be the way I would actually treat the swallow cell,
but it would help with circulating tumor cells.
And that was your question.
So as far as treating the swallow cell in our clinic,
we get a cheek swab,
we test for what we think is the cause,
how to deal with that,
we test for what we think is going to be the best attack of a cancer.
Plus, I would definitely consider getting it right.
I mean, it's quite the same for me.
It's dangerous as well,
I don't know.
So it's not something to play around with.
You'll want to get at it as fast as you can.
So this case,
I would highly suggest you go on our website,
schedule a case review with me,
and you can discuss it.
Okay, I want to question time on that question.
Is there any remedy for bone marrow injury
where you don't make B cells anymore,
due to drug toxicity,
chemotherapy, and retuximate?
Right now I have to,
and I have to go in for IV,
infusions of gamma-globulins
to replace my old,
immune system.
I don't want to do this the rest of my life.
Yeah, that's,
it is very hard.
You're trying to renew tissue,
and there is,
there's some nutrition that you could do
to help with
bone marrow production.
I'd have to think about that a bit.
Honestly, I don't have that on the top of my head.
Again, probably we schedule a case review with me
because we can look at a nutritional approach for this.
But it's just going to be supporting that.
And I presume you're getting these measured
when you go in.
So you could test and see whether a nutritional approach
would help.
But it is,
it is part of the danger of doing people
therapy.
You damage other tissue.
And the most susceptible to damage are tissue
that is highly metabolic.
Cell lines that are highly metabolic.
That's your,
your immune system is a cell line that's highly,
highly metabolic,
and your hair follicles are highly metabolic.
That's why with people go into the chemotherapy,
they lose their hair because it's,
your chemotherapy is going to have predilection towards
higher metabolic cell lines,
which is good because that's what cancer is.
And we want to attack the cancer,
but it also attacks those other cell lines.
So it could really damage our immune system response.
And that's why when you go in for chemotherapy,
infusions they have to test your white blood cell code
because typically you have the diminished white blood cell
code because you have a diminished ability
to make white blood cells.
Next question.
Do you have any help from a 33-year-old daughter
with insulin resistance?
She does not have diabetes,
but has several email problems with PCOS and endometriosis.
So, yeah, so insulin resistance.
You can have insulin resistance,
even with somebody who's not overweight,
even with somebody who has had a good diet,
meaning that they're not like a sugar holic.
Typically, if they could somebody with insulin resistance there,
you know, they're pre-diabetic or they're diabetic,
and it's because they've had to eat a really poor diet.
Now, I have no idea what's the first and so to eat a good diet or not.
But those are the kind of things that you want to look at.
Insulin resistance is damage to,
partly the insulin receptors,
the cell membranes.
Partly has to do with pancreatic function.
And it has to do also with,
it does tie.
So, it is interesting, this person said it,
except several email problems with PCOS and endometriosis.
I would definitely run some lamps.
So, a Dutch test for sure is in order with this,
and a Syrex array 5 would be appropriate for this.
You've got to, you've got to do some investigation.
So, with anything when you're talking about,
oh, why do I have insulin resistance?
Or why do I have PCOS?
So, why do I have endometriosis?
You need to go to a doctor who's asking those questions.
Why do I have this?
Let's investigate.
A few weeks ago, we had some questions on,
like, what's your protocol for this?
Or what's your protocol for this?
And I sounded like a broken record because I don't have a protocol for that.
We have to find out why you have that.
So, these disorders or dysfunctions that we often call diseases
are really, you know, signs that something else is going on.
So, PCOS and endometriosis and endometriosis,
our signs and other things going on from a metabolic standpoint.
So, we've got to dig in to find out what the reasons why those are.
And that's where we have to run some tests.
And I know some people are like, oh gosh, these tests are expensive.
Okay, well, you're never going to get to the root of these things,
unless you dig in and figure this out.
So, I would definitely run some tests.
Definitely, our product disease and autoimmune course would be good.
And a good, a good case revealed with me would be a good thing to do too.
Next question.
Do you go anything to help with a tonight's?
I have tried several natural methods with no avail.
It seems it's nothing from conventional medicine.
Yeah, tonight is there is no easy fix for tonight.
Because tonight is now thought to be actually inflammation
and damage of auditory nerve and inflammation.
It can be inflammation in your brain.
So, there is a, I have a blog post called,
if you go to our blog and you look up neuroinflammation,
I created a video, it's about a half hour video,
a neuroinflammation at microglial primate.
I highly suggest you go and watch that.
That's nice how to do it tonight is because if you have inflammation in the temporal lobe of the brain,
the sides of the brain, that's what your auditory center goes into.
If you have inflammation in microglial primate in there,
that can be a cause of tonight.
So, treating tonight as an inflammatory disorder is probably your best bet.
So, going on higher dose flavonoids,
I would give that a try.
I would also give a try to delta-total treatle,
which is the center portion of the vitamin E.
There's four central components of that.
Those are called the total treatles.
Delta-total treatle could be good for the ear.
So, not to get too technical, but you have certain parts of your body.
You have bascularization-eating vessels that are feeding it.
And that's your source of oxygen to that tissue.
Those vessels are what are called terminal vessels.
So, terminal vessels means you only have one vessel that goes to that area.
You don't have other vessels.
When you have tissues that have other vessels, those are called anastamosine vessels.
So, you have other sources of fuel, in this case, oxygen to that tissue.
Well, in the inner ear, and in the heart, you have,
that's two main parts of your body that you only have terminal vessels.
And when you have constriction of those vessels,
that's usually due to inflammation in the...
Underneath the lightening of the vessel, which is the endothelial layer,
you have smooth muscle.
And you can get inflammation in there.
It causes contraction of smooth muscle.
And you have contraction of those vessels.
And you have an impedement of flow through that vessel,
which causes a lack of oxygen, which causes damage.
It's in your heart. You have a heart attack.
Well, in your ear, you can end up with loss of hearing emptiness.
So, that can be an issue.
Well, the Delta Tocotriotol, which is that center part of the vitamin E,
can be very helpful to help open that up.
I would try Delta Tocotriotols.
And so, remember, it's not just vitamin E,
because that's going to be an alpha to cough or all,
or alpha-bated delta to cough or all.
That's not what you want.
So, you want the center part of the vitamin E.
I would also watch that video,
neural inflammation and microbial primed dental explode.
Call me down the inflammatory cytokine response in the brain,
which could be in the temporal lobe causing the tinnitus,
which you use high-dose flavonoids,
which are flavonoids that are like curcumin,
porcelain, bromelain, stingy nettles, anti-inflammatories,
resveratrol, EDC2, things like that.
So, watch that video that may give you some clues too.
What do you recommend as the top healing strategies for severe rheumatoid arthritis?
Well, rheumatoid arthritis is an autoimmune disease,
so you have to dig in to find out what the triggers are.
Are there food triggers?
Typically, the food triggers pretty much across the board
with rheumatoid arthritis are lectins.
So, definitely gluten, maybe dairy, but lectins.
I would join the chronic disease in autoimmune course.
It's 50 bucks to join that course and start working through the videos on that course.
I go into agonizing detail of looking, finding your triggers
in an autoimmune disease.
So, if you don't find your triggers in your autoimmune disease,
you're not going to get better.
So, it can be something, like I said,
typically through the throat arthritis, you have to stay with lectins.
But, there's very commonly multiple triggers.
So, I have people with rheumatoid arthritis stopped lectins.
That's not good.
That really helped me a lot, but I still have these layers.
Now, you start looking for triggers and putting it on your Sherlock.
And it's like, yeah, every time I go outside with high-polyd times,
that is a trigger for me.
So, everybody's triggers are going to be different.
Remember, every time you have autoantibodies,
that's what any autoimmune disease is.
But, you have antibodies to self tissue.
You have time to stimulate your immune response.
You're going to kill that which you have antibodies again.
So, you're going to flare your autoimmune disease
when you have any trigger in your body that stimulates an immune response.
So, even chemicals, toxins that you bring in that can stimulate an uptake
in immune response, you're going to feel worse.
So, you've got to figure that out.
And you can do tests.
You can do antibodies to different chemicals.
You can do antibodies to foods, because it can be some weird component
in a gluten-free product that you're eating.
You can do antibodies to micro-organisms, biotoxins.
You can do tests for those things.
If you have antibodies to ST-MAR,
you can say every time you're going to be exposed to that again,
which is pretty much ubiquitous.
It could cause a flare, and that could be your trigger.
You've got to figure those out.
So, highly recommend you take that course.
Spoon of colors, clinic again, top courses.
It's cheap to do, and I give you a ton of information
on how to self-help yourself through those things.
You can order labs from the course.
It's highly beneficial.
So, I'm not pushing it.
It'll make a whole lot of money on it.
But I just am constantly adding new stuff to that course,
literally weekly.
So, any new information that I come up with,
I might make a video about it or a slide presentation about
or something you can put it on that course.
So, do that.
Next question.
My 18-year-old daughter was diagnosed with stage 2B melanoma a year ago.
We've been on a holistic health journey during this year,
and her gastroathetic doctor had suggested she do a liver cleanse.
Her blood work showed elevated liver enzymes.
My question concerned about the protocol of the liver cleanse
to do a large amount of apple juice for the malic acid benefit,
but will the high amount of sugar be bad for her
patient that will take to feed the cancer?
So, do we eat a liver cleanse?
First of all, I don't ever have any of my kids or patients
do liver cleanses.
But I wouldn't do a liver cleanse if my alkylid boss or AST
or ALT came back elevated.
I would try to figure out why it's elevated.
Certainly, maybe this doctor did and came to the assumption
that you're congested liver.
I've got really big on liver cleanses.
And the reason is, is that, okay.
So, understand.
In the liver, you have phase 1, phase 2, phase 3 detoxification pathways.
These are controlled by different,
dependent upon different nutrients and controlled by different genetic pathways.
Looking at, when we look at a person's genetic pathways,
if they have issues with their cytokine people
or 50s or pun, one pathways, they're NHG pathways and such,
then we try to support those pathways.
I go into detail on this in my book, the seven phases of detoxification
and, of course, with that same name.
So, those three phases are three of the seven phases of detoxification.
Many times you have elevated liver enzymes
because you have blockage downstream from that.
So, you have congestion in the liver not because we need to do a liver cleanse,
but we have congestion in the liver because of gallbladder issues.
We have congestion in the liver because of issues in the gut.
So, we always want to start as far downstream as possible,
which is what I call phase 6.
Then we work up phase 5, phase 4,
and then you are supporting those phase 1, 2, 3 pathways,
necessarily doing a cleanse.
Now, the cleanse that this person is talking about using apple juice,
I think I'm familiar with that cleanse.
We even have information of that on our detox course,
but it's really used to help with the gallbladder,
helping to flush the gallbladder.
So, the question is, really, should I be concerned with the sugar in the apple juice
to feed the cancer?
So, I guess my answer to that question would be no
because you're doing this for a week, typically.
So, the apple juice and the malac acid content for the apple juice
is to help soften the stovings in the gallbladder.
You may prior to this desire to get an ultrasound or the gallbladder
to see what that looks like.
That may be something you want to look at.
But I would also investigate other possible reasons
why those liver insides are elevated
because they should not be elevated in an 18-year-old person.
So, lots of times liver insides can be elevated
due to even sensitivity to different nutrients.
If you're taking high-dose nutrients,
the naturopaths will put you on a bunch of different supplements
you may have actually have a sensitivity to it.
Remember, anything that you take in and absorb that your body can use
has to go through the liver to go through the detoxification process,
phase 1, 2, 3 to get out of the body again.
So, anything that you absorb into the blood has to get out of the blood
or be deposited into the tissues.
And if it's something even in nutrient that your body doesn't need,
it can over-stress the liver.
So, one of the mistakes that I see with people
coming to me with a cancer diagnosis,
they're on, in my opinion, maybe way too much stuff
and too much of a good thing can be a bad thing.
So, other things that could raise,
other most common things that could raise liver insides
is toxicity issued to a medication.
So, a person is out of medication.
Even ad-built or Tylenol,
that's a major issue of raising liver insides.
So, I'd be trying to investigate what's causing the elevation
of the liver insides.
And maybe you already did that.
I don't know, you're just asking a simple question here.
So, to answer the simple question,
what I'd be concerned about the glucose levels in the apple juice
doing a week of the liver cleanse,
I guess, no, I wouldn't be concerned about that.
And I do think it would be wrong to me not to give you
that other information to investigate.
Okay, next question.
For a person with a metastasis to the lungs,
what are some ways to best support lung function,
dealing with weasiness,
we're at a coffee, a slightly flim.
Okay, so, there's some herbs that can help,
certainly.
Again, I don't know anything about this person at all.
Was it metastasis from the liver?
Was it metastasis from the breast?
Remember, whenever you have metastasis of cancer,
it's not a new primary cancer.
So, let's say you have breast cancer,
it's metastasis to the lungs.
It's not lung cancer.
It's still breast cancer cells that are in the lungs.
So, breast cancer, the metastasis to the liver,
it's not liver cancer, it's breast cancer in the liver.
So, of course, you're doing everything you can to kill the cancer.
So, I hope that that is a given.
But what do you do for lung function is the question.
You know, weasiness, coffee, a flim.
Well, you want to make sure that you're expelling everything.
So, there's a purpose in a cough.
And you want it to be expelling that.
So, make sure the person stays healthy enough to be able to cough,
make sure they stay in a position where it's easy to expel that flim.
That's important.
There are some different herbs that can help with that.
Lobelia is an herb that helps with the lungs.
The first one that I think of always with the lungs
is medicinal mushrooms called corticeps.
So, corticeps has a very strong lung support.
It can even kill cancer that's in the lung,
whatever type of cancer it is.
But it's very, it's one of the best things to help heal the lungs.
And then the anti-inflammatory.
So, you think that Boswellia, curcumin, bromelade, ginger is very good for the lungs.
So, and then there's some discrepancy of using,
with using glutathyle and nebulized glutathyle.
Because it's cancer in the lungs, I don't think I would do that.
I just wrote an article.
So, anyway, as a cancer, it suggests you go to our blog post.
I just did it either this week or late last week and posted it.
About heartic seed.
The dose-dependent oxidizing effect of different nutrients to help kill cancer.
So, it explains that cancer already,
cancer cells, because they're in rapid replication,
because they're not replicating really super healthy cells,
especially mitochondrial healthy cells,
they are more susceptible to oxidative stress.
So, I go into detail in the article.
So, I won't spend a lot of time with that.
But you're at this level of, so, when a cell is undergoing oxidative stress,
it can kill the cell.
And the oxidative stress, the negative of oxidative stress,
it can cause damage to cells.
It can cause cancer.
So, oxidizing agents, toxins in our environment,
can be a cause of cancer.
It can damage cell membranes.
It can damage mitochondria of cell.
It can damage other organelles itself.
So, that's a bad thing.
But, cancer cells, because they're rapidly replicating,
they're not replicating a healthy mitochondria.
And it's the mitochondria that is mainly responsible
for making glutathione in a cell,
which glutathione is your main cellular antioxidant.
So, the glutathione is protecting the cell from oxidative stress.
So, in a healthy person, in a healthy cell,
you could say we need more components for glutathione,
which would be anacetylcystide,
which would be taking glutathione in cell,
because it's going to help decrease oxidative stress
on a healthy cell, so it doesn't get sick.
So, it's able to make energy well.
That's a mitochondria, too.
It's able to, you know, protect against cancer,
causing oxidative stress.
But, with a cancer cell,
it's already making a lot of excess reactive oxygen species
because of the nature of the cancer.
And it's that you have like lethal dose, you could say.
So, if you could put it on a bar graph,
your lethal dose of oxidative stress,
maybe right here,
while a cancer cell is already functioning
with the lethal, with their oxidative stress,
the reactive oxygen species just below that lethal dose.
So, if you could tip it over,
that's really what chemotherapy does.
People therapy is an oxidizing agent,
so it's adding reactive oxygen species to a cell
to basically kill the cancer.
Well, the idea is,
dose, apparently, there's different nutrients
that have been shown through different studies
to actually be maybe antioxidants in a normal dose,
but there actually are oxidative agents, higher dose.
So, you're actually taking a higher dose of this
to kill the cancer, to actually act like a natural chemotherapy.
So, go to that article,
I talk about four different nutrients
that work in that article,
but the converse of that is true.
Do we really want to use glutathione
or etacetal cysteine with people that have cancer?
Because then, could we not be keeping cancer alive
by, you know, it's really close to that lethal death
that reactive oxygen species,
at lethal dose of reactive oxygen species, intercellular,
and if we give it anti-oxidants,
could we be protecting the cancer cell
and TV cancer cells alive?
Well, that's been a debate about natural
and standards of care doctors for a long time,
and I have fallen always on the side of,
I don't think we should be giving cancer patients for the final.
But of course, we do testing in our office,
so we do cheek saw testing.
So, we have a few patients that I do have glutathione,
not very many.
So, taking anti-oxidants,
high dose anti-oxidants for a cancer patient
might not be the right thing to do.
But if a person didn't have cancer,
and the reason I'm talking about this is because glutathione
and an acetylocystine are so good for the lungs
and cleared out that waste of the lungs,
but if they have metastasis in the lungs
that I'd say no on that,
there's a longer answer just to get to that point.
But I think it's important.
Next question.
The doctor has prescribed a CT scan
of the abdominal area for my husband.
We know that the test involves sub-radiation.
Are there precautions to take before
after such a test to reduce the negative effects?
Thank you so much.
So, yes, the CT scan produces a lot of radiation.
So, out of all the, you know,
what are called plate film x-rays,
or, you know, just a regular x-ray
if you went through a chiropractor,
got an x-ray of your cervical spine.
The highest dose x-rays was called a chest x-ray,
because you leave the way it's set on the x-ray machine,
you use more radiation.
So, always, you always measure the dosage,
the rad dose of radiation,
that you're getting from something based upon a chest x-ray,
because that was how they originally measured this.
So, yeah, CT scan is like getting 50 chest x-rays.
So, that's a lot of x-ray.
So, that's a lot of radiation that your body has to deal with.
So, what do you do?
What do you do with all that radiation?
Well, your body has to get rid of it,
just like you have to get rid of, you know,
the damaging effects of oxidative stress.
So, that's exactly what radiation is.
It creates reactive oxygen species in your body,
and you have to help get rid of that.
So, I always recommend people that are doing CT scan or a PET scan,
because that's radiation too.
To use radiation holiopads,
you could see it on our store.
There's another holiopath made by professional health products
called radialgen.
I think it is radialgen.
So, I think if you just type it in our store of radiation,
you'll see those two holiopads that you can take.
And I just go through the whole bottle of it
and follow the holiopathic,
follow what's on the bottle as far as I want to take it.
That could be really helpful with dealing with radiation,
radiation toxicity.
Okay, another question came in as a patient,
who has been using the right for six weeks now,
and having issues with my colostomy, liquid output for weeks,
very fast, sometimes six a day.
Could this be a part of detoxing?
Try to figure out why.
I started a probiotic.
Any suggestions would be appreciated.
Okay, so whether you're having
a bowel waste, come out of a colostomy,
tube and bag, or into the toilet,
you have to investigate, you know,
if there's a change in consistency, why that is.
So, certainly,
certainly looking at possible intestinal infection would be good.
Well, you know, I wouldn't necessarily jump to like parasites
or anything like that, but looking at infection would be very appropriate.
Both common intestinal infection would be HPI lower eye,
followed by other bacterial infections,
or uncommon intestinal infections.
Could it be something as simple as just imbalance
and inflammatory process?
Yes, food sensitivities, bloated issues, dairy issues,
are your most common things.
So, looking at diet, investigating that,
doing a Syrex 2, Syrex 3, Syrex 4, or Syrex 10 array,
would look at food sensitivities and things.
You could certainly do stool sample test.
You want to investigate.
So, those are the things that you would look at for a change in bowel habits.
What is going on?
Certainly, if you don't have finances to do the test,
you have to experiment with maybe, you know,
a diet that's, you know, you're taking things out of your diet
to see if there's something that you're eating that is causing this.
Yeah, you have to do some trial and error of those,
because running some labs would be appropriate.
I hope that, you know, your oncologist is recommended,
regular CBCs and complete metabolic panel,
because that can tell you right there.
If you do a CBC and you have white blood cell count,
that's over 7.0.
They'll say it's normal,
but you definitely have an infection going on somewhere.
So, and then if your symptoms are bowel related,
you could, you know, make it assumption that baby,
that's where I have an infection that I have to deal with.
So, if you do have a bacterial infection in the gut,
you know, from the medical standpoint,
they're going to probably recommend antibiotics.
If you do that, you absolutely have to be taking probiotics.
It's going to throw up your microbiota.
But if you have, if you're more inclined to do an alternative approach,
thinking of, like, burberry and garlic and things like that,
would be more appropriate from a natural perspective
to try to deal with this.
What should come in from a Facebook?
What supplement is good for a person who is recovering from a heart attack?
So, a heart attack is, kind of we were talking about before,
where you have a mischievous blockage of, you know, nutrition, oxygen,
to cardiac tissue, and you have to go, well, why?
So, it's easy to go let's lead cholesterol,
you have high cholesterol, you have cholesterol, you have clacky.
But this is not always true.
First of all, if you do have elevated cholesterol,
you have to look at liver function.
You might have elevated, you might have cholesterol clacking,
and not have high cholesterol, because you have damaged to the arteries,
because you had high whole assisted levels for a period of time.
You may have an eschemic attack because of what I said before,
you actually have a deficiency in delta-total triadal,
so you have a contraction of your smooth muscle
under the endothelial layer,
and that's, it was just a eschemic attack because of contraction of that,
or that's not a permanent contraction,
that's just damaging the blood flow for a very short period of time.
So, there's a lot of reasons why.
So, again, with any treating, anything, you have to try to treat the reason why.
So, you've got to figure that out.
The nutrition for somebody post heart attack giving them cardiac tissue
can be helpful to rebuild function.
There is a product from Biotics called Cytosine H,
that is cardiac tissue that is good for the heart itself,
looking at taking a full spectrum vitamin E.
We use that for cancer patients that have private labelled the product called K-POP-E,
that has the delta-total triadal in it,
and then addressing the reason why,
by addressing either lipid issues or endothelial damage issues,
or chronic undiagnosed H-Pyro-I, or a diagnosed Lyme,
a diagnosed heavy metal toxicity, those are the three most common things
that could damage endothelial cells and damage cause contraption of the smooth muscles
and cause head blood pressure.
So, all right.
Well, we have to sign off, sign up patients that they get to.
So, thank you for being on.
Make sure you go to our site called holistichelpour.com,
holistichelpour.com,
and go to Cutters Clinic,
and search for questions out there,
cause we have tons of blog posts that you may actually find a question out there.
All right.
Everybody, believe blessed,
and we'll see you next week,
get your questions in,
and hopefully we'll get to answer them.
Thanks so much.